who's our home affairs correspondent
mark white has been on a boat in the
English Channel today and witnessed
already seven different incidents of
migrants attempting to get into the UK
this comes as the government has
promised to get tough on migrant
crossings as hundreds of people have
been intercepted during the coronavirus
lockdown mark white joins me now live
from Dover mark thank you for being with
us tell us about what you've seen
well Adam we saw some significant
rescues underway in the English Channel
overnight and into this morning
it is meteor problem of course according
to the Home Secretary pretty Patel who
is diverting extra resources to this
side of the channel and to her
colleagues in France with a view to
trying to intercept these boats before
they can even leave the French course
well what we saw heading into the night
at 2:00 a.m. this morning into the
pitch-black into the middle of the
channel was the first of a number of
rescues that happened actually just as
dawn broke over the busy shipping lanes
out into the channel we saw this migrant
boat 13 men and women on board that
vessel and it was actually being
shadowed by a French patrol board now it
had been shadowed pretty much from the
moment it left the beach in France that
vessel was with it for some two hours as
it made slow progress towards the
English side of the English Channel that
is of course the goal of these migrants
to come across here to claim asylum when
they get to the English side once
they're taken to Dover we as I say saw
the French boat out there then the
border force vessel as well this is a
flavour of what we witnessed we can see
the French patrol boat Aramis circling
the area while the border force vessel
speed well is now down in front of the
migrants port they just got them to stop
their engines they're about to try
to get the migrants from that ball
transferred onto their vessel now there
is some concern that French authorities
may not be overly enthusiastic in their
efforts to try to intercept these
vessels on the French side of the
English Channel and are perhaps more
than happy for them to hand into British
waters before border force here in the
UK intercept them this is what we heard
from Matt Coker who is the skipper of
the boat we were on to be honest that's
not the first time I've seen that as
quite regular they don't seem so
interested in stopping the vessels as
they do so they scored them across yeah
and but it intercepted that vessel in
French waters it did yeah just a few
miles from the shore so I mean it was a
few hours passed before they reached the
actual border in the middle of the
channel
well the border for special speed well
intercepted those migrants and fairly
quickly was able to take them on board
they were clearly at that point willing
to shut down their engine according to
sources we've spoken to the issue really
is that migrants just are not compliant
with the French because the goal is to
reach the English side of the channel
and to be taken to Dover so once the
border force are on scene they will then
switch the engine off and they're
willing to board the board these border
force vessels now that particular border
force vessels Speedwell was heading back
into Dover when it got too cold to
another rescue it headed off to pick up
another six migrants and then entered
Dover Harbour with 19 migrants on board
at the same time as that was happening
the Dover lifeboat was out picking up
two separate groups of migrants another
border force vessel the cutter searcher
and another vessel the border force boat
hunter were also out picking migrants up
in separate incidents
sixty-five we managed to count them may
well have been more in the time that we
have been back on shore again but
another significant day and really a
repetition of what happened yesterday
with some 64 migrants who've crossed the
channel as I say the Home Secretary Adam
says that they are investing more money
it's a top priority for them they say
the French are on board that the French
are as committed to trying to stop them
getting off the beaches in the first
place but it's clear when they're in the
water the migrants clearly don't want to
stop they want to continue until they
get in to the English side of the
channel and then are intercepted by the
UK border force now what is the legal
position on this because Nigel Farage
has also been out reporting or alleging
that the French are in fact assisting
people crossing the channel into the UK
what do you understand the international
law the French should be doing about
these boats well if they are in French
territorial waters then the legal
position is quite clear Adam and that is
the French of a duty to try to intercept
pick up these migrants and return them
to France
home of a spokesman said that they have
done that the French authorities have
been doing that and in the past week or
two you have returned 155 migrants back
to France but the issue they are coming
up against is that when you have
migrants not willing to comply going a
different course that the French patrol
boats are trying to make them go and not
switching off their engines the French
then have no option but to continue
shadowing because they have a duty in
terms of a safety to life duty that they
have as well so they stay within easy
reach of the vessel should it run into
trouble but if it's not going to switch
off its engine they're not going to run
a small rubber dinghy like that
effectively just waiting for it to cross
into this side of the channel and for
border forces to come and intercept it